[Musique]
bonne soirée à tous je ne suis pas seul
devant vous deux hommes et une jeune
femme sont à mes côtés
christian boisseau est un chômeur de 27
ans jacques coeur est le dirigeant d'une
entreprise moyenne
quant à marielle goitschel je n'ai pas
besoin de vous la présenter
tous trois m'accompagne pour porter
témoignage dans le grand combat que je
mène
vous le savez je voulais dit je vous
tiendrai le langage de la vérité
le redressement de la france est
nécessaire pour que nous soyons parmi
les gagnants de la grande compétition
qui dominent le monde
la première étape du redressement
c'est le redressement économique sans
prospérité votre pouvoir d'achat est
atteint votre emploi est menacé
vos rêves de logement ou de loisirs
peuvent s'envoler en fumée
à la longue c'est l'indépendance de la
france qui est atteinte et son influence
en europe et dans le monde
les malheurs aujourd'hui de la france
s'appelle hausse du chômage hausse des
prix depuis sept ans plus de cent mille
entreprises ont fermé leurs portes
le nombre des chômeurs a été multiplié
par quatre les prix ont doublé
et vous mesdames ce que vous pouviez
acheter en 1974 avec un billet de 50
francs
vous ne pouvez pas l'acheter aujourd'hui
avec un billet de 100 francs
voilà une faiblesse pour toute la france
c'est aussi un malheur pour vous c'est
un malheur en particulier pour les
jeunes
christian boisseau témoin je m'appelle
christian boisseau je suis chômeur je
viens de châteauroux c'est une petite
ville de 50000 habitants située dans
l'ain j'ai suivi des études pour être
technicien en bâtiment
au début je vais trouver une situation
dans une entreprise qui construisaient
de petits pavillons malheureusement très
vite à cause de l'augmentation du taux
des crédits les gens ne peuvent plus
faire construire
la conséquence c'est que l'entreprise
doit licencier du personnel
et comme j'étais un des plus jeunes je
me suis retrouver chômeur depuis je
cherche un emploi
mon univers c'est les petites annonces
et l' agence pour l'emploi et dans les
petites villes les possibilités de
trouver du travail ont pratiquement
disparu j'ai 27 ans et franchement ne
rien faire quand on a 27 ans c'est moche
on à venir
je ne vois pas je ne peux pas faire de
projets ni dans ma vie professionnelle
ni même dans ma vie familiale
je suis obligé de vivre au jour le jour
voilà le résultat de plusieurs années de
pilotage à vue au jour le jour
cette situation ne peut durer quand un
médecin se penche sur un malade il peut
lui apporter un calmant pour apaiser sa
douleur
s'il ne cherche pas la cause du mal il
ne le dira pas
nous avons autour de nous de nombreux
médecins et même certains charlatans
il en est qui disent s'il ya trop de
chômeurs c'est parce qu'il y a trop de
jeunes attendons que le nombre des
jeunes diminue elle chômage baissera
ce raisonnement est une honte la
jeunesse est l'atout de la france ne l'a
sacrifions pas d'autres disent pour
réduire le chômage
il suffirait d'augmenter tous les
revenus est de diminuer tous les impôts
au bout de la route
il y à une nouvelle augmentation des
prix
une nouvelle hausse du chômage d'autres
encore vous dise
il faut créer des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois dans la fonction publique et
décrété une réduction générale du temps
de travail au bout de la route
il y a des dizaines des centaines de
faillites d'entreprises et des milliers
de travailleurs qui vont grossir le
nombre des chômeurs il faut être sérieux
et chercher la cause c'est à dire la
racine profonde du mal la racine
profonde de la hausse excessive des prix
et du chômage
excessif la vérité ta voix si il faut
d'abord une politique raisonnable des
rémunérations la course accélérée entre
les prix et les salaires conduit
toujours à faire des victoies faire des
salariés des victimes
l'état doit chaque année
après consultation des syndicats et si
possible avec leur accord
fixer un taux modéré mais régulier
d'augmentation des salaires et des
rémunérations
en contrepartie l'état exonérera les
contribuables qui paient moins de 5000
francs d'impôts par an la vérité c'est
aussi qu'il faut alléger les charges des
entreprises industrielles et agricoles
il y a dix ans les entreprises
travaillent est un jour sur trois pour
l'état et la sécurité sociale
aujourd'hui elle travaille quasiment un
jour sur deux c'est dans la compétition
mettre des fers aux pieds à notre
économie c'est comme si l'on disait à
marielle dans une compétition
prenez deux vieux skis en bois et
laisser de côté les skis en fibre de
verre non la vérité est également dans
un effort d'économie l'état vit
actuellement au dessus des moyens de la
france augmentation raisonnable des
rémunérations allègement des charges
économie telle est la politique
raisonnable la politique raisonnable qui
doit donner des chances de gagner dans
la compétition les chances de gagner à
la france ait des chances de gagner pour
vous voilà un discours portif il est
différent des autres discours politique
c'est pourquoi je vote michel debré moi
je peux vous le dire
michel debré le seul candidat qui peut
se présenter au départ d'une compétition
sans être disqualifié je suis fatigué et
les français aussi de ses éternelles
discours de droite de gauche de ces
mêmes chansons qui ne nous apportent
aucune solution
michel debré lui est différent nous qui
me regarder et qui m'écoutez l'essentiel
n'est pas de discuter sur 35 ou 36
heures de travail sur 42 ou 43 jours de
congés payés
de toute façon vous le savez bien ce ne
sont que des promesses électorales qui
ne seront jamais tenues
ce que nous voulons c'est une france qui
gagne
michel debré lui élève le débat car il a
la dimension d'un homme d'état ce que
d'ailleurs personne ne lui conteste en
effet il est lucide il voit clair et il
dit la vérité aux français
michel debré est alors monette et quand
j'entends les gens me dire il est trop
honnêtes gens répondent
oui nous voulons un président honnête
vous savez la france va crever de faire
un gars de la politique
voilà pourquoi spontanément j'ai choisi
de suivre michel debré si les
entreprises françaises avec dynamisme de
marielle elle serait sûr de gagner
encore faudrait-il qu'on ne vienne pas
briser leurs efforts jacques tord
dirigeant d'une entreprise moyenne vous
apporte son témoignage je dirige depuis
deux ans une entreprise qui fabrique des
articles de pêche sur l'activité se
situe donc dans un marché en
développement celui des loisirs
vous savez aussi que de nombreux
français sont passionnés par la pêche
nous produisons des cannes à pêche de
réputation mondiale
notre chiffre d'affaires se développe
rapidement
nous exportons notre entreprise peut
donc être considérée comme une
entreprise dynamique et performante
et pourtant depuis quelques temps nous
sommes confrontés à un problème
dramatique celui des importations
d'extrême orient
elles ont doublé en cinq ans ceci a
causé des difficultés énormes pour mon
entreprise
regardez une canne à pêche importées de
corée coûte moitié prix que la même
canne à pêche fabriqués chez moi que
puis-je faire
j'ai été oublié d'abandonner des
fabrications
j'ai dû le fermer un atelier en fait
c'est toute la profession qui est touché
des entreprises ferment et un employé
sur trois est licencié il est facile de
comprendre la percée des fabricants du
sud est asiatique
il sous paient leur main d'oeuvre ne
paye pas de charges sociales
nous sommes donc confrontés à une
concurrence déloyale
c'est intolérante en fait si aucun
remède n'est apporté c'est l'avenir de
mon entreprise et celui de ma profession
qui est menacée voilà où nous conduit
dans cette profession et dans d'autres
le laisser faire cette entreprise
fabrique de bons produits et pourtant
elle peut être condamnée à licencier il
faut savoir la protéger tout de suite on
nous dit mais pour vendre à l'étranger
il faut acheter à l'étranger donc
laisser nos frontières ouvertes
cette argumentation est simpliste
le japon exporte il exporte même
beaucoup or le marché japonais est
protégé super protéger les américains
exporte beaucoup
le marché américain est protégé dans
certains secteurs
super protégés l'allemagne exporte
beaucoup elle aussi est à l'intérieur du
marché commun elle s'est protégé
certains de ses produits
oh il ne s'agit pas de revenir à une
protection nationale aveugle et
généralisée il s'agit de protéger nos
secteurs menacés des textiles à
l'électronique en passant par
l'automobile et sans oublier
l'agriculture
il s'agit aussi de négocier en position
de force
nous avons tous été humilié quand il y a
quelques mois les ministres européens
français y compris sont allés en chemise
et pieds nus demandé au japon de réduire
ses ventes
il faut qu'il aurait fallu d'abord
imposé des droits de douanes et des
contingents et négocier ensuite en mai
nous avons envoyé nos régiments de
cavalerie avec leurs sabres contre les
chars d'hitler nous savons résultat dans
la compétition économique
il nous faut des armes adapté nous avons
créé le marché commun pour établir une
zone de saine concurrence à l'intérieur
de l'europe et non pas pour faire de
l'europe une passoire
français françaises je vous le dis avec
solennité
si la commission du marché commun de
bruxelles dans les semaines qui viennent
ne change pas de politique nous avons le
droit et même le devoir
de protéger nos secteurs menacés comme
le dit marielle ne soyons pas plus bêtes
que les autres et si nous ne faisons pas
d'autres secteurs seront foudroyé des
entreprises fermeront leurs portes et
des travailleurs par milliers iront
grossir le rang des shs les rangs des
chômeurs
c'est une fois cette protection établi
avec intelligence que nous pourrons à
l'instar du japon des états unis de
l'allemagne
avoir une politique industrielle et
agricole de reconquête du marché
intérieur et en même temps développer
notre offensive sur les marchés
extérieurs afin de rétablir nos comptes
qui en ont bien besoin
c'est pourquoi j'estime nécessaire après
l'élection présidentielle de constituer
un gouvernement ferme une équipe
cohérente qui recevra la mission
d'appliquer cette stratégie du succès
voilà je vous l'avais bien dit michel
debré est le seul capable de
sélectionner une équipe de france
politique ni un problème que je ne
comprends pas bien en sport quand on
sélectionne une équipe de france on
prend les meilleurs de tous les horizons
l'équipe de rugby qui a gagné le tournoi
des six nations
ce n'est pas seulement béziers ou
narbonne le malheur pour la france c'est
que chaque parti a la prétention
d'incarner la france
michel debré lui il est au dessus de la
mêlée et il est capable de constituer
une équipe politique
vous voyez quand j'ai gagné mes
médailles
ce n'est pas pour la droite ce n'est pas
pour la gauche c'est pour la france
michel debré c'est le candidat de la
france
[Musique]